bonjour à tous je suis ses couilles le
texte est qu aujourd'hui nous allons
parler du savoir vivre ensemble
alors pourquoi parler aujourd'hui du
savoir vivre ensemble parce que depuis
plusieurs années la presse se fait
souvent l'écho de la croissance des
incivilités occasionnés par des citoyens
quels sont ces incivilités
ce sont tous ces actes et comportements
qui manifestent l'ignorance ou le rejet
des règles élémentaires de la vie
sociale
en d'autres termes ce sont ses faits et
gestes souvent sans gravité excessive
occasionnés par des personnes qui ne
respectent pas les règles du savoir
vivre et qui rendent la vie ensemble
moins agréables et faciles qu'on résume
et l'incivilité exprime un manque de
courtoisie ou de politesse soit en actes
soient en paroles avez vous des exemples
d'incivilité les incivilités peuvent se
traduire dans de multiples situations au
bureau dans le quartier sur la route
dont les magasins à l'école et cetera
cela va des poubelles renversées aux
voitures garées devant des garages au
tapage nocturne les insultes au volant
esquivé pour passer devant la queue à la
caisse du supermarché arriver chaque
fois en retard à une réunion etc
ils peuvent faire pour diminuer ces
individus toujours diminué ces
incivilités
il faut réapprendre la civilité à la
population et surtout aux enfants ce
coin laussucq douteux qu'on peut
traduire civilité tard savoir vivre ces
mots désignent en effet la même chose
c'est la capacité d'observer des
convenances des bonnes manières en usage
dans un groupe social est un pays
il peut aussi parler de respect ces
règles de savoir-vivre sont elles les
mêmes dans tous les pays ghoul
elles ne sont pas les mêmes d'un pays à
l'autre ainsi il est normal au danemark
de tutoyer tout le monde alors que ce
n'est pas le cas en france
aux états unis on se serre soit même à
table quand on est invité à manger chez
des personnes quelles sont les règles de
savoir vivre en france les règles de
savoir vivre en france sont nombreuses
et variées
elle concerne les situations et un
endroit où on est en contact avec
d'autres personnes manquent et de
savoir-vivre mettra les autres malades
les chocs raoult leur rendra la vie
invivable voici quelques exemples de
règles pour un meilleur savoir vivre
ensemble sortir ses poubelles les jours
prévus à cet effet cédé sa place aux
personnes âgées et aux femmes enceintes
dont les transports en commun diminuer
le volume de la musique le soir
weill est ce que les toilettes publiques
restent propres respecter les biens des
autres
j'espère que vous avez compris ce qu'est
le savoir vivre ensemble et que vous
l'appliquerait dans votre vie de tous
les jours à bientôt pour un nouvel
épisode